it is great to be joined today by
christian picciolini who's founder of
the free radicals project host of
breaking hate
on msnbc also author of the book white
american youth and his story
of leaving neo-nazism and white
supremacy
is would be fascinating to us at any
time christian but it is particularly
interesting and relevant given a lot of
what's been going on in the united
states for the last couple years
so maybe we'll start with your story i
mean you got into the movement pretty
young at 14 i believe
how did that happen what's the genesis
of it
yeah and david thanks for having me on
um
i was recruited when i was 14 years old
in 1987.
i was very early uh in you know kind of
this version 1.0
of the of the white nationalist movement
that we're calling it today
uh i was a neo-nazi skinhead in fact
that was one of america's first
um you know what led me there
essentially was i think what leads every
uh
person to this movement and and that was
my life's
potholes uh those traumas i think that
kind of nudge us from our path
and lead us down you know pretty dark
corridors for me
it was a lot of uh you know abandonment
issues low self-esteem
uh my parents are actually italian
immigrants so it wasn't something i i
was raised with at home
but because my parents are immigrants
when they came over in the 60s they had
to work
very very hard and i never saw them so
they were gone seven days a week 14
hours a day and i really struggled with
uh you know thinking what i had done uh
you know had pushed them away
potentially and and i was never you know
really brave enough or
knew how to ask or to communicate those
feelings so i i
kind of went astray at a very young age
um searching for identity community and
purpose and
and not really being able to find it
until one day at 14 years old i was
you know standing in an alley smoking a
joint and this guy
pulled up in a car and he got out and he
had a shaved head and he was wearing
boots
and he walked up to me and he pulled the
joint out of my mouth and he said
that's what the communists and the jews
want you to do to keep you docile
and smoking pot will keep you docile so
that then
they what take over or control you or
society
exactly yeah it was it was their method
of control
over us one of you know one of their
many conspiracy theories about
you know how uh you know jews were in
power to control
and destroy the white race through
multiculturalism and
uh you know the feeding of drugs into
white neighborhoods and things like that
i mean it was ridiculous
obviously looking back now but at 14
years old for somebody who
you know had hit a wall as far as
acceptance over and over and over again
and was bullied and
felt very marginalized when this man who
was america's first neo-nazi skinhead
walked up to me
it was as if he was offering me a
lifeline i didn't understand anything
about the politics i didn't understand
you know racism
it wasn't it wasn't something i was you
know even aware of
because i lived in such a small bubble
uh
meaning my my family's home i didn't
really go out very much i was kind of a
very solitary kid
um so you know it it offered me kind of
a way to belong and
and it didn't matter what he was selling
i think i probably would have jumped at
anything at that point
so what i mean what was being sold in
terms of what were sort of like the key
principles or you know talk a little bit
about so you you get pulled in somehow
you're either invited to come to some
meetup or group or in some way you start
building these relationships what were
sort of like the predominant
themes or ideas that were being
discussed
well i mean at first it was it wasn't
about any kind of ideological beliefs or
even themes it was about
just drawing me in because of uh you
know my lack of
acceptance in the past the savvy
recruiter uh
you know and recruiters in general
recognize that that i was vulnerable
because of
uh you know my loneliness my
marginalization and they
essentially swooped in and offered me
paradise and then the types of things
that they would start
talking about started off fairly benign
they would
uh you know this man who saw me in the
alley actually after he snatched a joint
from my mouth
and said that you know went on to ask me
what my uh
name was and i told him and he
recognized it was italian and then he
started to praise
uh you know italian and roman
civilization as being
uh you know great thinkers and warriors
and
and artists and that i should be proud
of that and you know being an italian
kid growing up in an italian
neighborhood with
you know fully italian parents i knew
all about that stuff so i was very proud
of that
but then when he started to um you know
after he pulled me in through this sense
of pride then he started
over time to try and say that people
were trying to take that pride away from
me weren't trying to diminish it and
then
of course went on to name the groups of
people and it started with uh you know
jews who who wanted to manipulate and
control
you know that was his his conspiracy
theory uh
that african americans were uh you know
were lazy and only uh good for selling
drugs and crime and that they were
destroying our neighborhoods
uh which you know my neighborhood was
changing and i didn't see any of those
things but
it seemed plausible to me at the time
what's interesting about that christian
is that there's this idea of the fear of
the loss of status
right and that underlies a lot of the
resurgence
we're seeing in the last couple of years
around some of these ideas as well so
that
that was a big thing you're saying the
fear of someone's going to take your
status from you
well well here's the thing i mean white
supremacists are very good at creating
the desperate conditions for people to
live under and then
using those desperate conditions to
actually
create fear of them and place that blame
on somebody else so not only not only
are they creating the conditions
but they're feeding them constantly
through fear rhetoric and by blaming of
the other
and that's what's happening today i mean
we you know we hear things like
multiculturalism is is white genocide
uh that you know white males are are
being
targeted as as uh as you know
the most evil people on earth right now
and and that their identity is being
taken away
and you know frankly none of that is is
true uh
white males have done a lot of awful
things in our history and and i think it
deserves to be called out just like you
know other people have done awful things
uh
you know in our history and and uh it
certainly doesn't paint
a whole species as as bad uh
however um you know the recruiters and
and the propagandists are very good at
kind of identifying these very
simple um kind of
controversial talking points like free
speech
or white civil rights or the fact that
you know
they claim that people can't be white
and proud and they use all those things
to kind of
pull out essentially pull out the racism
in people that was dormant
by making them afraid of something that
could happen to them but is certainly
not happening
how does the line get crossed and maybe
it's not so much a line but it's a
blurry area
into violence and the stockpiling of
weapons for a potential race war like in
your path how does the transition happen
from where it's just
here's a group where i can kind of feel
not like an outsider they're welcoming
me
where i belong to the ideas that you
just told us
and then go beyond that into actual
violence and and getting weapons and
preparing for a race war
excuse me uh you know i think it's about
desperation and uncertainty
the more we you know we people get into
these uh
extremist groups because most times
they're looking for acceptance they're
looking for identity they're looking for
purpose
and while they may find those things to
some degree in these types of movements
what it actually does is it further
marginalizes them from society
uh and you know i think if desperation
and uncertainty uh
you know grow to a point where a person
feels that there's nothing that they can
say or do
that will uh give them any acceptance
or you know any sort of um camaraderie
or identity then
you know the potential is there if there
are underlying issues
like mental health issues or um
feelings of revenge uh that can't be
critically thought out you know then
sometimes it does lead to that
but i can tell you that you know there's
this
this whole notion that you know we're
calling white extremists or white
terrorists mentally ill and that we're
not calling them terrorists and i do
agree with that i do believe that we
we have to call white extremists who
commit terror terrorists
but at the same time you know it's also
true that we do tend to paint
uh most white actors in this space as
people who are mentally ill
versus you know people of color who are
doing this as terrorists
right off the bat the truth is is that
mental illness is
really the underlying factor uh not just
for white extremists but across the
board
um i tell you about 75 of the
of the people that i work with um
are either living on the autism spectrum
or
with asperger's or schizophrenia or
bipolar
and i'd say 95 percent of those people
are
either undiagnosed or untreated and i
think that a lot of that having to live
with that you know not only does it
cause social marginalization growing up
uh you know maybe they were looked at as
odd or strange or
or somebody that you know couldn't they
couldn't be friends with that pushed
them away and the combination of all
those potholes those traumas
i think is what leads people to that
desperation and that search for
acceptance in really negative pathways
can you talk a little bit about the
conspiratorial element of it because
even in the conspiracy world generally
there is this disproportionate
appeal as i think you say to individuals
who are struggling with different
emotional or mental illness type
conditions where
they have maybe slightly more of a
propensity to be
pulled into some of these ideas and one
of the sort of hallmarks of
conspiratorial thinking
is that both evidence for and evidence
against
is evidence for right the fact that
there
is a piece of evidence that seems to go
against your conspiracy
is part of the conspiracy right either
because it's planted evidence or
whatever we all kind of understand how
that works
does that take on a particular dynamic
within the world of
white supremacy in other words the idea
that uh if you have a counter example
about
jews aren't really conspiring to do this
or that
well that's part of the conspiracy
they're making you
think that they're not conspiring how do
you even deal with that type of thing
i don't i don't ever debate with anybody
about ideological topics i you know i
listen a lot
and and i i'm able to filter out that
noise of those conspiracy theories maybe
it's because i
you know for eight years of my life i
used to say them and now i
they sound you know utterly ridiculous
to me uh
so i'm able to kind of tune in uh and
focus in on on those potholes like
what really led them there is it abuse
is it
you know trauma is it mental illness is
it poverty is it extreme privilege
whatever those things are though that's
what i'm listening for i try not to
to engage you know into an illogical
debate
even if i am using logic because it just
doesn't penetrate it has to be kind of
an emotional connection
uh but to answer your question i mean i
think you know there are certain
aspects and characteristics of people
living with certain disorders that
that would uh you know kind of foster
unidimensional thinking or a hyper focus
on something or
a natural lack of empathy um
and you know and and i think the
structure of the movement the structure
of these conspiracy theories is very
appealing to people
uh who you know maybe see outside
stimuli uh as you know kind of like
noise that they can't
uh settle um so you know this the rigid
structure of
very black and white thinking the you
know the
facts that are presented uh or sorry the
conspiracy theories that are presented
as fact
kind of provide some comfort i think to
people who
uh you know might have um a lot going on
in their head that they don't understand
and uh it draws them in it provides some
answers to them
and you know it's i think conspiracy
theories are
are what are driving these movements and
they have for you know
decades and decades um you know and even
centuries i mean these tropes these kind
of anti-semitic tropes and
and uh you know garbage
science about you know race and iq and
and
uh you know ideas about
identity and misogyny things like that
are all you know part of these movements
and uh you know what scares me the most
though david is today
there are people out there very you know
famous podcasters and and
writers of books with new york times
bestsellers who are pushing these same
types of you know identity and junk
science tropes that are so consistent
with the white nationalist movement
that either willingly or or sorry
wittingly or unwittingly
are spreading these it's causing so much
damage and leading so many people
towards this movement that i'm not even
sure that
they're aware they're doing it yeah
that's actually exactly what where i
want to pick up the conversation in part
two of the interview we've been speaking
with christian petrolini who's founder
of the free radicals project
host of breaking hate on msnbc and also
author of the book white american youth
and that's exactly where we'll continue
our conversation
on tomorrow's program